der series den ort etwas ruhm by any
means
scheiße sehr gut drucker
hallöchen freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen map
vorstellung heute wieder zusammen mit
martin hatten wir schon ins länder
angekündigt dass wir eine web vorstellen
werden
und zwar haben wir uns die far cry 3 map
ausgesucht wir haben gesehen dass die
youtuber wir hätten die hedge films
glaube ich halte den film hat film oder
adventures ich weiß gar nicht genau
ich mache daraufhin let's play das ist
auf jeden fall sehr cool aber wir
wollten nicht einfach nur kurz
vorstellen weil die märkte extrem geil
es wurde unter anderem auch von playmate
et cetera gepusht wenn er auf dem dach
und wir sind halt hier gespannt und
wollten da jetzt einfach mal so ein
bisschen rum gehen und so ein paar
sachen hier angucken das erste was wir
von ihm schon gesehen obwohl er bei der
keller
war schon sehr interessant jetzt noch
alles so ein bisschen verwüstet und da
als ich weiß nicht was ich hier sehe
blog like this just en
titel review of yourself up when you can
make things i das ist das ja far cry 3
easter eggs
ist der
vip loge
portland
war mein gott far cry 3
buch ich bin gebildet von gut gemachte
die ganze welt was das wort wn dp world
über platform to your right
ja hast du ne na.de
weil aber sind hier herrliche kulisse
hier dann müssen wir eben wieder rüber
werfen mit wieder hinkommen
robert in der perle herrin abhängen kann
man nicht wer hier ist enorm kreativ
geht das war nicht anders geht dann
nicht geben könnte wenn die un-mission
der ptb vielfalt beim you can use them
to the third and challenges was hast du
als trainer gerne
gebrauch einer drin gewesen kann ich
jetzt nicht immer noch da unten einfach
na ja gut aber das wollte ich nicht
machen sondern wir wollten uns einfach
nicht angucken
das heißt ich gehe in den game mode 1
und wollten gegen ein bisschen rum des
new york fliegen von dort bis zum
rechten web zeigen ok cool ich komme mit
martin
spinnen jetzt schon wieder fest
der challenger des kritischen oben alter
sitte war ja schon cool hier aus als
wenn das alles wirklich selber gebaut
und muss ich sagen respekt also hier
findet wie immer download linken texture
pack und soweit es in der beschreibung
oder hinten ist brot
hier nach oben geführt du bist mir
hinter vor mir sogar
du bist wieder unsichtbar da bist du
bist unsichtbar du café haben zu sagen
nur
benötigt hätten
klargestellt
da geht es zu rot und hier steht und gut
ich habe jetzt hdf gelesen alter hit
cola strand jetzt im bund hier sind so
stramm körper wahrscheinlich so hast du
darstellen
so halbe baumstämme dass das dazu sieht
alles bisher sie mich ziemlich cool aus
muss ich sagen ich gebe auf sport
gehören brot genauer bot sich ein
schalter gesagt und nichts passiert hey
cool ich bin im boden hier ist auch eine
kiste mit einem schwert
hatte ich sehe da hinten irgendwas im
münsterland hinten
all das sieht schon krass aus
respekt ist wirklich glaubt deshalb dass
beide abgestürzt es werde abgestürzt ja
weil es bewegt sich nichts mehr ja dann
beende das ist irgendwie mannschaft ja
wieder keine ahnung vielleicht einmal zu
klappen oder so aber dann ist glaube ich
auch der anruf weg egal dann ruft mich
daneben noch mal an ja wie gesagt martin
der sitzt gerade neben ihr mit
dem laptop mit meinem laptop mit meinem
macbook und deswegen kann mir da
teilweise ein paar problem schon bei mir
sachen aufnehmen okay sind auf jeden
fall noch ein paar sachen tische stühle
ja und wie gesagt dass der andere
vielleicht kommt ja
was heißt
da muss man machen
hier den laptop
ja ja hass hinzu geklappt jetzt muss
wieder aufklappen
ok
ok martin hat probleme mit seinem laptop
im laptop sache sein also ich gehe mal
ganz kurz noch ein bisschen rum was ihr
so zu sehen ist also wie gesagt bei der
app hier wirklich alles selber gebaut
ich weiß nicht ob ein bisschen tropic
kraft benutzt wurde so dass es dann so
ein mod
eine mod
das ist auf jeden fall schon mal sehr
geil was also der strand hier sind auch
wasserfälle falle keine ahnung was er
verlangt also nicht
dass ich auf jeden fall sehr cool aus
einer diese wand das ist ja das soll
mich berge darstelle das sieht nicht
sehr schön was muss ich sagen also
dieses material
aber sonst muss ich sagen bisher gefällt
mir die map sehr sehr gut
einmal kurz drauf drücken
meinte massa ist kaputt
also hier ist dann so die berge das sind
da unten ist ein kleines dorf oder sehr
schön ja so ein kleines mini dörfchen
noch mehr häuser geht's wieder martin
geht es wieder
habe ich ja gesagt heißt er auch machen
das heißt macht ihnen das vielleicht
wieder
wieso bei mir funktioniert alles geht
nur nicht wenn du da in die disco ihren
kombi
eventuell sollten die dateien und gesagt
wir werden kein let's play von dieser
map machen sondern richtig mit nur kurz
zeigen weil wenn ich habe zurzeit eher
schon today show lässt also ich hab
schon zur zeit schon viele projekte
deswegen erstmal nicht oder irgendwann
nicht so
cool hier ist ein cooler see
was ja mach mal
hallo martin hallo noch da ist er wieder
teleportiert du dich zu mir
ja und dann telefoniert sie bisher
wissen ist so hier ist jetzt ein kleines
dörfchen
zumsteg also dass das bisher so die
schönste ecke finde ich welche wirklich
so ein dorf mit dem strand und dann ist
sondern see startet denn da hinten
scharf mitten im see sohn schaffen so
thomas sonnenburg aber keine ahnung hat
ziemlich aufgebaut
naja irgendwie sowas
teleportieren sie sich zu mir ich bin
dabei
was sich in game mode wenn ich
das bisher schönste finde ich
das ist das was mir
da kommt
ja er ist gut ja hinter dir du fliegst
hat die ganze zeit vor mir weg ins
länder auf einmal neuesten werk wo bist
du das machst du denn da seien falsche
richtung hat auch gesagt ich bin auf dem
see man spart ihn ja ach da
aha
also ich jetzt net.de
ja das meinte ich das hat sich führen
aber bei mir noch nicht ganz aufgebaut
und was das glaube ich einfach
irgendeine ruine wieder irgendwie so ja
sieht auch sehr noch aus vettel kann
ohne ja
ich bin oben drauf noch nicht schauen
ich bin drauf nein doch nicht ja ich
aber nicht
hier geht's zum artikel hier ist eine
frau ist ja hier ist der kirche
in denen lasst uns erst mal die kanone
gehen da kannst du nicht rein doch klar
ist auch extra seinen weg nach unten hin
die schon gesagt hat wir sind betten
wäre schön gemacht sehr schön und
skeletons
noch mehr druck jetzt sind wir hier
drinnen dann aber einen schönen ausblick
das muss ich sagen
ja
jetzt sind drei porsche noch hält da
brauchen wir auch voll gut wenn wir so
creative sind und so naja gut weil wir
weiter gehen denn kleinen dingen ja
jetzt zu der kirchenkonzerte dinge
kaputt
v der minecraft 100
wo bist du denn er
sieht aus wie ein flughafen jedoch nicht
erst zum flughafen
es ist ein auto dann irgendwas anderes
fenster
das linken stand
dann guck mal was die ölpreise haben
hier könnt ihr euch das betanken
einmal viel zu teuer hier ist ein
geschäft irgendwie mit klamotten oder
soja auch wo das so irgendwie plätzen
oder so was
jetzt eine garage und auch auf wird und
stick also die merkt jetzt echt für
sonnen dingens ausgelegt für den let's
play dass man da ich schon ein paar
sachen findet halt alles um far cry 3
stil openworld worldspan monster und
gegner
schon sehr cool gemacht ich gebe meinen
die kirche rein ich gehe mal in
hotelbars
mayrhofen betreiben mit meinen büchern
ich kehre ich jetzt auch schon in
chloe zonen die oeg trotta warte ich
komme auch in die kirche
tnt zu sein
momentan ist die luft springen mit erst
mal angucken
also hier
was war da schon
ach so ja macht ihn ein wirklich okay
war ich bin dir drin war was machst du
denn
weil wir bräuchten
können wir nicht zu
also ich habe einstein schwert so kann
man den reichen hier heute erstmal
anboten
hey wo mein vater da hab ich ihnen
schwer feste
orale
hast du schon dem hotel hier hmm da ist
nichts besonderes hotelbar dass ein
fernseher
besonderes
hier ist etwas angeschlagen
ist ja so ein komischer spinner
hier brennt was ich habe das bonner cup
im
hotel weil wir ein bisschen weitergehen
ja
kommen sie mit jetzt mal irgendwas hier
war glaube ich auch noch nicht doch da
waren wir schon ist der anfang warte ich
hab auch ne karte
leider da waren wir auf jeden fall noch
nicht damit nur noch ein bisschen hin
kommen wir also da hätte ich sehe noch
von hier aus so ein schiff
großes schiff erwartet wo bist du hinter
dem
komma ich geb dir mal die karten kannst
du das angucken
da
ok einer kuh
geht darum sind wir erhalten wird ist
aber groß
martin wo bist du kommst du hinter mir
herzlich bei mir bist du noch auf dem
boden
jetzt bist du weg
kommen sie mit
ja lass uns mal da hinten indien und auf
dem also das ist ungefähr die richtung
wo ich jetzt ins linke eck
ja ich hab noch die karte geguckt
was das
wird auf der karte angezeigt martin wo
bleibst du ich bin über die
rote karte
trägst du nämlich und bist nicht über
mir naja liegt an die tradoria und dem
macbook macbook muss sagen dass merkel
gesagt sehr laut das ist korrekt waren
so ist auch gerade da wo wir sind also
ich bin hier zum turm da
gott was war das wo bist du okay du bist
neben mir hallo
sind verblödet zombies stehe
was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich für
ein turm muss sagen die gegner aber
komische geräusche
weiß ich nicht wahrscheinlich irgendwann
fernsehturm finden sie mussten uns wäre
da oben kein redstone drauf
höchstwahrscheinlich
weiter in diese richtung ich bin auf dem
weg kommt es mir daher
so ab weiter in diese richtung da sind
immer noch so ein paar barrikaden aber
die müssen wir uns jetzt glaube ich
nicht alle angucken sondern einfach eine
normale welt mit ein paar mit word alles
in sachen ausgetauscht so die bäume
waren das gebaut man im endeffekt muss
ich sagen ist das alles sehr sehr schön
so jetzt am strand angeblich ersten
stunde war da ist eine kleine
und dahinten müsste gleich in seiner
nähe von dieser insel da
schauen wir uns mal die getan um eine
hütte
erste eingang
hannah hütte
hier ist ein steak der macintosh area
ausgepackt hier ist
jetzt geht's wieder
ich weiß nicht was du alles nebenbei
noch geöffnet hat hellwig cool cars
import halt was hast du denn alles noch
nebenbei geöffnet martin
spotify an wieso ist mail an alter ich
bin auf einmal in etwa und jetzt bin ich
gleich wieder draußen gehen ich in die
portale auf gar keinen fall
ich hab gesagt die nicht in etwa martin
jetzt kommen wir nicht mehr raus
ich sage noch gehe nicht endeavour und
der geht ins
regal lassen was so ein ding ins portal
walter ist hdtv
ist okay stimmt das ist lavastein recht
denn hier dann ganz langsam
hätten die gleiche textur das ist
komisch postkarten portal ich brauche
mal obsidian sieht es hier aus
lette wolle
kompetente rentenalters lothar gans
aufsuchen ach ja stimmt ja ich hab
ich wollte dir den dingen ist ein
feuerzeug
ja
wieder draußen halter bekommen wieder
heraus
haben weg nach oben frei gegeben
alter wo wir sind wir
wir sind komplett weihnachts
rausgekommen aber ich weiß ungefähr wo
teleport der ich doch mal zu mir alter
ich bin
wieder da beim dingens beim strand von
vorhin
david flix herum
so kommst mir daher steht das gesamte
schiff
ich sehe ich schon
dahin müsste gleich irgendwie so ein
stück sein
aber wir dass da nicht jetzt nee das
muss hier sein dass es auf der karte
angezeigt ich sehe da irgendwas auf den
boden ja das ist aufrechter schiff das
schiff müsste jetzt hier im moment vom
ihr auftauchen ich bin ich schon längst
drüber
us-sender fehler ich dachte schon wir
hier jetzt noch einen see oder so
dass da sieht interessant aus alter das
ist das
was ist das was das für ein wegmann
scheint aussieht so sehr wie eine straße
ist ein schild
hoch
ja ich bin hinter dir
du bist
wir können jetzt im airport ruhe
flugzeuge
warten gleich hinter dir hab alles ja
den ganzen weg warte bis zur airport
gelaufen ja okay bin
ich brauche ein flugzeug
ich bin jetzt am airport ich sehe dich
jetzt ein auto
ich gehe mal das gebäude räumen
ich bin direkt hinter der series in
nordend etwas ruhm by any means
scheiße sehr gut drucker
der standort entert ruhm und da dachte
ich okay dann gehe ich da mal rein
befestigt ich war jetzt zu kaufen gibts
flugzeuge dann hab ich irgendwie alle
sunday setzte die ganzen
container hier
echt interessant ja alles
jeweils schalter naja gut wie mehr auf
der map zu sehen
was ich meine das nicht negativ kommen
was ist ja schon menge was wir gesehen
haben ich habe dir erwarten
martin wo bist du siehst du mich
denn vor diesem großen loch was ich
gezeigt habe
ja ich werde ich gut kommt mit daher
okay gut kommentar her da wäre noch
vielleicht irgendwas also da waren wir
auf jeden fall noch nicht hier das eine
brücke oder so
und jetzt auch noch ein fettes gebäude
aber da müssen nicht unbedingt ein gehen
jetzt die brücke
die sich doch auch schön aus
kreisen war ich war ich gerade nicht
dass man mit main cup weiter fand
irgendwie langsam
ein genie schafft das nicht kommen wir
wieder zurück
nach manno ich dachte mein gott fahren
jetzt von alleine nein
doch tun sie ich hab nach vorne gedrückt
das wird jetzt nach vorne
das ist nun mal nicht
hatte ich glaube die strecke hat die da
hinten auf
ja die heute hier auf das bringt nichts
mehr ist als ich auf jeden fall sehr
interessant als interessent
hier ist das gebäude
daher sei das gewesen wo ich gesagt habe
dass wir da noch hin könnten der brand
ist rennen ein mal reingehen
muss der eingang da wo du bist glaube
ich oder den unternehmen wir stehen ja
you better be quick building ist er baut
kollaps ok oh
ja aber vorher kenne ich aber fangen wir
fast kein holzes
ich bin in den katakomben
jedoch nicht dass der eingang der
unternehmen gesetz macht ihn nahe wie
man es gerade in luft geflogen oh
ich schaue mir das ganze mal von oben im
alter gibt sogar mehrere etagen ich bin
ich wegen wie hakt das schon wieder
scheiß macbook
bei deinem pc hat es natürlich nicht
ich darf erst runter gefallen naja gut
ich würde sagen dass war es erstmal von
der far cry map ich glaube jetzt noch
mal kurz zum strand am richtertisch in
der ecke zu zeigen hiermit soll da ich
würde sagen
falls euch das video was ich mache
einfach / will dann bin ich da wieder
respawn
meine lieben freunde wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich sagen gibt einen
daumen hoch downloadlink texture pack
und so weiter findet eine beschreibung
und dann will ich sagen mit diesem
tollen ausblick auf dieses schöne schiff
sagt martin dichters matches und dieser
far cry 3 map die ich wirklich sehr
schön gestaltet finde oder also ich
würde wenn es in zehn diamanten ranking
gibt würde ich damit locker zehn
diamanten geben also ich gebe dir 10,5
ja gut aber ich finde ich die hat es
verdient also das war bestimmt von
arbeit brauchen vulkan
naja ok